là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux ni non
j'aimerais beaucoup que je m'apprête à
tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins et si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le trophée les valises à paris de
ce qui lui arrive à la bulle comme
chaque semaine france info et l'ina vous
offre un voyage dans le temps à travers
les archives de la télévision pour mieux
comprendre l'actualité contemporaine
celle inattendue
vous êtes les bienvenus à mes côtés
ludivine lopez et camille d'auxerre
journaliste à la rédaction de l'ina
bonjour à toutes les deux alors qu'abby
vous avez choisi de revenir sur la forêt
amazonienne qui aimait désormais plus de
carbone qu'elles n'en absorbe oui la
presse s'en est fait l'écho cette
semaine parce que c'est un basculement
historique
une étude a montré que depuis 2010 la
forêt amazonienne qu'on appelle le pont
de la terre à rejeter plus de carbone
qu'elle n'en a absorbé 18% de plus alors
la faute au réchauffement climatique aux
activités humaines et à la déforestation
un homme alerte depuis longtemps il
s'appellera honni c'est le chef du
peuple gaïa peau et ont 89
il a quitté sa forêt amazonienne pour
venir pour la première fois sur un
plateau de télévision en france regardez
place maintenant à notre invité un
invité pas comme les autres il s'appelle
raoni il vit dans la forêt amazonienne
ça nous intéresse beaucoup la masoni
parce que cette forêt est le poumon du
monde et qu'on a besoin de son oxygène
est ce que vous aviez pensé à cet aspect
des choses
non ils jouent à la cab nous allons
inaugurer la cab au bar tabac toute la
baie il dit que si nous continuons à
détruire toutes les forêts non seulement
nous allons détruire les animaux les
rivières etc et les indiens m'aiment et
tout le monde
tout le monde va mourir voilà c'était il
ya plus de 30 ans et on continue
toujours à malmener cette forêt
amazonienne
alors ludivine vous c'est le sort des
de nuit qui retient votre attention je
vous interpelle en tout cas cette
semaine
oui malheur vous montre ça me manque
timoré ce sont d'ailleurs les grandes
oubliées du déconfinement c'est comme ça
que les appels certains journaux ces
derniers jours fermé depuis plus d'un an
leur réouverture n'est pas prévue au
calendrier du déconfinement d' emmanuel
macron pour les professionnels du
secteur sur les 1600 établissements
français un tiers pourrait disparaître
avec la crise du coc vide
il est loin nathanaël loin très loin le
temps des premières discothèques
françaises c'était dans les années 50 et
les actualités françaises s'intéressait
aux phénomènes regarder deuxième station
la discothèque sanctuaire où le common
entre pas mûres qu'aucune lamentations
ne saurait et brûlé seul dans le monde
319 bien heureux détenteurs d'une clé
peuvent y pénétrer car pour franchir le
seuil de ce paradis il faut la clé
évidemment ce paradis et son terrain là
onze mille disques parmi les plus rares
offres ou 319 élus ont choisi
inépuisable de danse rituelle exécuté
dans une atmosphère tout de quiétude et
de recueillement mais dites moi il ya un
côté très sport ben oui le sport tir est
une grande place à saint germain des
prés sur tous les sports d'adressent
mais c'est vraiment dans la danse que
l'existentialisme tour sa plus belle
expression
voilà une autre époque nathanaël qui
vous manquent sûrement les années 50
j'adore les années 50 voilà pour
l'actualité de cette semaine mais que
s'est il passé le 5 mai à travers le
temps regardez c'est le zapping de l'ina
et ça s'est passé
1 5 mai bonjour il est 20 heures
voici notre estimation des résultats de
l'élection présidentielle
jacques chirac est élu président de la
république avec 80 2,1 pour cent des
voix
jean-marie le pen 17,9 pour cent des
voix 20h20 au stade de furiani nous
sommes à quelques minutes du coup
d'envoi de la demi finale de coupe de
france bastia olympique de marseille le
stade de furiani est plein 18000
spectateurs
soudain les 15 derniers rangs de la
tribune principale s'effondre plusieurs
centaines de spectateurs se trouvaient
sur ces tribunes des supporters sont
bloqués dans l'enchevêtrement des
tribunes il faut vite et dégagent et à
marseille la nuit dernière un attentat
non revendiqué a endommagé la porte
d'entrée du palais de justice mais c'est
surtout en corse que les explosifs ont
fait des dégâts
c'est un triste record il ya eu 16
attentat dans l'île
et tous ces attentats viennent d'être
revendiqué en fin de matinée par un
nouveau mouvement clandestin
le front national de libération une
opération montée à la fois de
l'extérieur et de l'intérieur de la
grotte où se cacher les ravisseurs
l'aso très violent a duré près de sept
heures 17 tués 15 indépendantiste deux
militaires c'est un jour historique pour
la nouvelle calédonie l'accord de nouméa
a été signé par lionel jospin et les
principaux représentants politiques de
lille
il ouvre la voie à la souveraineté de la
nouvelle-calédonie d'ici une quinzaine
d'années un projet de loi
constitutionnelle sera présenté dans
quelques semaines en conseil des pistes
en avant une réunion du
congrès durant l'été est une figure du
dessin humoristique qui vient de
s'éteindre ainsi né et décédé ce matin
des suites d'une opération signer aura
marqué la presse de ses dessins et
caricatures politiques souvent au
vitriol moi j'avais des grandes j'ai
posé des grandes causes
mais bon je me suis cassé la gueule
cette série sons of war et 68 a foiré
bonsoir ya des nains
[Musique]
c'est un des points positifs
un des rares bénéfices de cette crise
sanitaire la france comme tous les
autres pays concernés par l'épidémie a
redécouvert découvert même diront
certains l'hygiène à nous nous sommes
jamais autant laver les mains depuis
l'apparition du coc vide dans notre
quotidien c'est même le geste barrière
numéro de camille oui le sujet très
sérieux nathanaël puisqu'il y à une
journée mondiale de l'hygiène des mains
vous ne le saviez peut-être pas c'est le
5 mai et ça a été créée en 2009 par l'
oms l'organisation mondiale de la ceco
même visionnaire par rapport à
l'importance de se laver les mains
quelque peu rond en tout cas maintenant
on va le savoir que c'est la journée
mondiale le 5
cette année le slogan c'est quelques
secondes pour sauver des vies nettoyez
vos mains alors le sujet forcément n'a
jamais été autant d'actualité avec le co
vide mais en france on a depuis
longtemps cherché à sensibiliser à
l'hygiène de nos mains avec pédagogie
avec sérieux et même avec humour
[Musique]
lavez vous les mains en chanson ou non
mais lavez vous les mains
ce geste d'hygiène et montrer répéter
n'ironise et à la télé depuis les années
50 pour les petits de la maternelle chez
la séance laborieuse de lavage des mains
bien sûr il y à des campagnes
officielles du ministère de la santé
comme celle de 2009 en pleine pandémie
de grippe a au quotidien une main peut
contenir et transmettre plusieurs
milliers de microbes mais le sujet se
veut aussi plus léger en 1964 se laver
les mains
c'est un geste beauté dans l'émission le
magazine féminin
sachez qu'il était un certain nombre de
choses qu'il faut éviter si vous voulez
les garder sous peu et belle l'eau trop
chaude comme l'autre ont frôlé par
exemple en revanche une eau tiède elle
aussi par un peu de bicarbonate est
parfaite
le bicarbonate parfait pour les mains
sèches qui ont subi des lavages à
répétition comme au gel hydro alcoolique
mais il a mis du temps à se démocratiser
alors à défaut en 77
cette sage-femme avait son petit truc je
prenais de la gnôle on me l'avait les
mêmes athlètes sur ça empeste et mes
enfants tant pis s était propre
c'est que l'hygiène des mains est une
priorité pour le corps médical
enfin a pour tout le monde a écouté ce
professeur en médecine en 1994 lorsque
l'on dit au personnel soignant aux
médecins que le geste le plus important
c'est le simple lavage des mains est
bien ce ce geste essentiel est un
message qui passe assez difficilement et
si on en ferme et les récalcitrants aux
toilettes par exemple voilà l'idée de
cet inventeur en 1998 avec sa trouvaille
impossible de sortir du petit coin sans
se laver les mains là si vous passez pas
vous sortez pas ou plus simple rappeler
les gestes de base dès le plus jeune âge
c'est la mission de ces étudiants
infirmiers à rennes en 1999 donc les
microbes qui sont sur les nerfs
ils vont dans la bouche en effet dans la
bouche dans la bouche après ça peut
faire des maladies l'hygiène des mains
le sujet est sérieux et il ya même une
technique officielle européenne en sept
étapes de 30 secondes chacune
démonstration en grand en 2011 sur un
madison à toulon pour alors le petit
geste paume contre paume dessus-dessous
pousse bien sûr et on termine par les
poignets après ça plus d' excuse
j'adore parce que c'est typiquement le
genre de petites chansons de petite
musique qui va rester quelques heures
dans le fond d'accalmie vous évoquez
dans le sujet ce fameux gel
hydroalcoolique incontournable depuis un
petit peu plus d'un an
il n'a pourtant pas été créée hier ah
non il n'a pas été derrière sa date y
avait déjà des jours de gel en fait dans
les années 60 mais l'hôpital a vraiment
adopté le gel hydroalcoolique dans les
années 2000 pour lutter contre les
maladies nosocomiales et il s'est
ensuite largement répandue en 2009 pour
lutter contre la grippe a ce gel est ce
que vous savez à qui on le doit non à
l'hôpital de l'honneur à la [ __ ] de
genève alors j'ai appris qu'il y ait au
docteur didier pittet en 99 il
présentait son invention à france 3 lyon
ce geste est devenu une habitude pour le
personnel soignant de l'hôpital
universitaire de genève avant chaque
soin quelques gouttes de chlorhexidine
rassure hygiène obligatoires on observe
qu'en moyenne une infirmière
de ce secteur devraient se laver ou se
désinfecter les mains 17 fois par heure
de soins
on l'a chrono mais fesci sont des images
in et 34 minutes par heure de pointe à
un patient et l'intérieur de graisse de
la veille que le gel hydro alcoolique
qui maintenant les mains réservée à
l'hôpital et il est entre toutes les
mains saison et je voulais vous gagnez
maintenant bon quoique l efficacité
décidément qu'à me voilà vous êtes là
c'était il ya quarante ans le 5 mai 1981
le débat télévisé de l'entré deux tours
de la présidentielle entre françois
mitterrand et valéry giscard d'estaing
réunissait plus de 25 millions de
téléspectateurs spectateur privilégié de
secondes télévision est devenue culte
serge moati bonjour serge des journaux
deadline merci d'être là vous étiez à
l'époque conseiller est là enfin la
cible au soir vous étiez à l'époque
conseiller audiovisuel de françois
mitterrand c'était plutôt rare à
l'époque un conseiller audiovisuel
comment ce rôle vous l'avez obtenu que
je suis rien obtenir du tout ça s'est
passé au congrès d'epinay en 1971
j'étais jeune militant socialiste et
chose rare un réalisateur socialiste de
télévision voilà j'étais jeune je
sauterai télé juste après 68 et
mitterrand voulait aller devait aller à
connecter siège de la rtf de l'époque et
il demande un de ses copains claude
estier n'y a pas quelqu'un dans ce parti
qui connaît un peu la télé que tron
estime me montre lui moi mais moi il ya
50 ans et donc les va changer il ya
vraiment si je me laissais les j'aurai
une larme d'émotion qui perdrait et est
donc
donc voilà il vient vers moi mais comme
à reculons je n'avais pas le look il dit
cette phrase extra bien mais qui est
irréel tout c'est comment il était
évidemment
je connaissais le cinéaste serge moati
je ne connaissais pas le camarade city
alors là et personne me connaissez bien
moi j'étais à il me connaît lui à votre
ordinaire et donc du coup juré fidélité
jusqu'à sa mort et je les tenues
fidélité
en tout cas vous avez largement
participé à la préparation de ce duel et
giscard d'estaing mais avant ludivine
vous vouliez nous montrer je crois une
photo une photo qui en dit long sur
votre rôle le rôle que vous avez joué
auprès de françois mitterrand entre 1971
et 1995 c'était quelques minutes avant
le débat 1980 alors on vous voit ou plus
près de françois mitterrand à quelques
centimètres de son visage je l'atelier
de jacques attali r d autre conseiller
de françois mitterrand il semble absorbé
par vos mots serge moati vous lui disiez
quoi à françois mitterrand à ce moment
là à ce moment là j'avais fait une rue
dont 80 j'avais inventé un truc c'était
en pleine affaire des diamants de
bokassa vous souvenez et la chanson
d'expliquer le terrain si vous aimez
être trop vous tapotez sur le dossier
jaune qu'elle a c'est ça que vous lui
dites est ma grande hotte la grande
confusion pour secret parce que c'est
très curieuse quand je te crève d'état
pour comprendre l'enjeu du débat de 1981
il faut quand même le rappeler est
remonté sept ans plus tôt le 10 mai 1974
premier face à face sur le rtf entre
deux candidats à la présidence de la
république en l'occurrence françois
mitterrand et valéry giscard d'estaing
déjà une première dans le paysage
audiovisuel français alors que les
américains l'expérimenté depuis 1968
voilà pour ce premier débat made in
france peu de règles à part patrick
l'égalité du droit du sol en tout c'est
qu'on dit des choses comme exactement
les choses tout à fait les deux
journalistes ou qu'on voit à l'écran
faisait le décompte mais interdiction
pour eux de poser des questions face à
un giscard assez sûr de lui qui oscille
entre eux ils étaient beaux regards
caméra et regard à son adversaire que
vous m'avez vraiment bien ce regard là
un mitterrand
moins à l'aise avec des nombreux
documents qu'ils consultent souvent et
nord 30 des changes donc en 1974 donc
beaucoup retiendront ça ce qui va
frapper
est ce qui me frappe dans ce débat je
m'étais ans je vous le dis très
simplement c'est que vous êtes un homme
du passé
c'est ce qui m'a frappé j'aurais
souhaité que nous parlions de l'avenir
j'aurai souhaité trois fois je ne peux
pas parler de l'avenir avec vous on a
l'impression que l'avenir ça ne vous
intéresse pas je trouve toujours
choquant et blessant de s'arroger le
monopole du coeur
vous n'avez pas monsieur mitterrand le
monopole du coeur vous n'avez pas j'ai
un coeur comme le vôtre qui bat sa
cadence et qui est le mien vous n'avez
pas le monopole du coeur et ne parlait
pas aux français de cette façon si
blessantes pour les autres
deux phrases daisy percute terrible là à
nous pour moi compris qu'on perde pour
beaucoup d'ailleurs c'est à ce moment là
françois mitterrand par le débat voire
même l'élection quelques quelques jours
plus tard vous êtes d'accord mais en
tout cas ces deux trucs ces deux moments
là les giscardiens était exulter et et
nous on savait qu'on perdait c'était
simple et quand il est revenu vers nous
à la fin de l'émission dure alors on
sera pas l'un de ces jours quoi énorme
on savait qu'on avait perdu quoi alors
françois mitterrand et la caméra vous le
disiez ça à l'époque ça faisait des ça
faisait 2 il appelait d'ailleurs là une
noire ah oui vous savez ça ça frôle eu
une crise qui se méfie de la télévision
parce que c'est un homme du temps des
meetings du temps des harangues
populaire des machins comme ça et c est
la télévision isimat qui je parle quand
je pars la télévision à qui alors la
prochaine fois je l'amène à cognac jay
là je reviens en 71
il me la voiture est une parle de ses
yeux noirs je maquille ya derrière tout
cas alors pour essayer de le faire et on
n'arrive pas en avant en studio et je
lis mais il ya peut-être derrière ses
caméras à ses yeux noirs quelqu'un qui
va voter pour vous savez pas ni c'est
pas drôle moitié d'accord ok merci et je
me risque à parler d'idées il ya
peut-être derrière cette caméra nom des
jeunes femmes c'est jeudi que vous allez
séduisent et là il va se marrer c'était
génial il se place par et on a notre
relation a commencé comme ça en tout cas
en 1981 françois mitterrand mesurer
l'enjeu à dire les visuels et politique
c'est beaucoup
80 il fallait prendre sa revanche sur le
monopôle geek c'est ça qui m'a fait
cette fois avec son nez avec son équipe
dont vous faisiez partie il décide de
dicter les règles
en voici quelques-unes présente à 20
jours avant le débat par un autre de ses
conseillers prédateurs formidable
monsieur françois mitterrand propose à
monsieur giscard d'estaing un face à
face télévisé mardi prochain 5 mai à 20
heures la durée 2h03 partie de 40
minutes chacune quatre journalistes
choisis d'un commun accord poseront
candidats les questions ceux-ci ensuite
en débattent entre entre eux j'ai
transmis cette proposition à la
commission de contrôle
c'est maintenant monsieur giscard
d'estaing de le faire connaître s'ils
acceptent ou non cette proposition de
françois mitterrand alors c'est tous
valéry giscard d'estaing accepte le deal
il me semble sympathique françois
mitterrand aurait préféré le contraire
bah oui oui parce que vingtaine vrai que
c'est beaucoup mais c'était ça passait
de la valeur des plans gros plans pour
cent matches à ne pas couper la parole à
voir les uns des manières des deux côtés
la distance entre les deux candidats ils
éclatent quand on parle à quelqu'un
proche
on peut parler autrement quand on parle
de quelqu'un pardon les cameramen dit si
c'est pas la même chose
donc il fallait tout régler comme ça
mais négocier avec eux avec les gens
jusqu'à et à notre grand détriment
ils ont dit oui à tous nous ont passé de
ça décrit un petit problème qu'on allait
provoquer un effet de presse quoi on
revient voir mitterrand pas d'intérêt
moi un peu penaud
un peu embarrassé et 10 ont toutes
accepté à nous à regarder vos châteaux
et deux nuls catastrophe pour lui vous
aviez échoué
oui on n'est pas bon quoi alors
justement on va parler de ce débat on
voit dans la manière dont s'est réalisé
beaucoup de gros plan de face à moi il y
en a moins sur valéry giscard d'estaing
bah oui qu'est nous vous le réalisateur
expliquez nous pourquoi
quel est l objectif de cette de ces gros
plans mais voyez sur ces gros plans la
voix six yeux et je voulais absolument
que ce séducteur de la vie qui était et
mitterrand vous pouvez aussi séduire et
dire je parle avec mon coeur aussi pas
simplement donc et je voulais absolument
que ça se voit jusqu'à a été plus grand
que jeune plus prolixe plus je sais pas
quoi mitterrand était comme ça va etc et
il fallait montrer ce qu'ils avaient
dans le coeur et dans l'esprit c'était
très important
en tout cas le jour j dans le studio 101
de la maison de la radio france à
mitterrand était prêt dans un décor
toujours très sobre
finalement comme l'avait dit seuls deux
journalistes en jean boissonnat et
michèle cotta face au candidat côté
mitterrand moins de dossiers sur la
table et un petit air de revanche
vous avez tendance à peu à reprendre le
refrain d'il ya sept ans l'homme du
passé c'est quand même ennuyeux que dans
l'intervalle ou soyez devenu vous
l'homme du passif
cela gêne un peu votre démonstration
d'aujourd'hui voilà @ entre qu'est-ce
que vous qu'est ce que vous avez fait
que vous avez entendu cette réplique
jeudi l'otan oui et ça on l'avait
travaillé quand même en à l'homme du
passif s'étaient ils étaient habitués
mal économiquement pour jusqu'à ce
moment là pardon mais en tout cas il ya
eu d'autres phrases fortes
je ne suis pas votre élèves voulaient
pas le président de la république ici
vous êtes simplement mon contradicteur
je souhaite gagner l'élection
présidentielle
je pense la gagner et quand je leur ai
gagné je ferai tout ce qu'il conviendra
de faire un cadre de la loi pour gagner
les historiens ça me touche quand je
vois ça parce que c'est c'était tout ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque l'union de la
gauche qui est si lointaine maintenant
il faut reconstruire tout ça c'est rare
dans le 10 mai 1981 françois mitterrand
est élu comme l'histoire retient
exactement 51 points 76 % des voix à
premier président de la gauche de la
vème république
quel est selon vous l'importance de ce
débat de ces débats télévisés dans dans
le scrutin dans cette victoire
je jure pas leur porter chance d 1,76
s'est pas beaucoup non mais c'est bien
mais je n'avais pas dit qu'il n'avait
pas perdu beaucoup non plus à la fois
dernière précédent le pastel mais enfin
c'est toujours ça se tient mais cela est
ce que cette victoire il l'a construite
sur ce débat théo je crois pas il avait
il était à l'aise il sentait que c'était
beau chaud mais pas au point de dire
c'est le débat qui a tout fait ça jamais
cette prétention quand même c'est pas
vrai c'est la france le peuple qui a
voté pour lui et quand même ce ne faut
pas exagérer j'adorerais me faire
mousser mais non non c'est lui c'est lui
ses conseillers ses équipes et serra et
d'union de la gauche encore une fois
c'est quand même important me l'union
juste à la fin du débat qu'est ce qu'il
s'est passé quand vous êtes sortis du
palais louchats des huîtres monsieur ah
oui avez-vous fait des huîtres il en a
mangé je sais pas quatre douzaines j'en
pouvais plus je ne pouvais plus je le
regardais gras monstre bonsoir voila le
21 mai 1981 c'est donc la cérémonie
d'investiture au panthéon la réalisation
ou la doua serge moati vous avez
continué de conseiller françois
mitterrand jusqu'en 1995 jusqu'à la fin
de son deuxième mandat
si vous aviez vous avez déjà peut-être
répondu à la question mais si vous aviez
un moment à retenir de toutes ces années
passées auprès de françois mitterrand
ce serait lequel le dernier c'est le
dernier moment
c'est la dernière fois que les vivants
si vous le permettez c'était les voeux
aux français je faisais les voeux chaque
année lui violé ces textes et il termine
9 e par année prochaine ça sera mon
successeur qui vous présentera ses voeux
était très malade je trouve pas à
l'elysée je ne trouve pas je veux
j'arrivais toujours une heure avant pour
répéter quoi pas de mitterrand personne
dans son bureau on me disait peut-être
dans ses appartements privés je connais
les appartements privés
il répond pas puis j'entends une voix
étranglée oui entrée était dans son
milieu pauvre et il me dit entrez entrez
dans son lit il dit cette phrase tu es
peut oublier les ja b gt c'est comme si
j'avais la gestapo au mois pour décrire
la douleur qu'il avait le pauvre pour le
pot là on était cinq mois avant la fin
de son deuxième mandat mais il était
très malade
un courage incroyable et il y ait des
mois me levais je l'aide à ce que je
tiens son texte si je vous permettez je
voulais jouer notre jeu tient entre ses
dents et je le dire comme ça et j'ai eu
et je tenais les mains je sais de
prompteur tivoli le texte
et ça se termine par l'année prochaine
sera pas moitié vous présenterez mes
voeux ses voeux ça sera mon successeur
je vous quitterai pas car je crois aux
forces de l'esprit et vous quitterez pas
à moi je sache fort émue et lui aussi je
crois une bissert vous souvenez les
forces de l'esprit ce tir oui monsieur
souvient il me dit habillé mois après je
l'habille comme je peux je suis pas
cousty mais si peu et on descend il s'en
va et redit à la caméra je crois aux
forces de l'esprit je ne quitterai pas
la juge thiel complètement il disparaît
la fois d'après quand les bus était sur
son lit de mort il est mort dans des
moments forts comme celui ci y en a
d'autres voulaient racontée dans un
documentaire qui sera donc diffusé mardi
11 mai à 23h sur france 2 c'est aussi le
le rapport de françois mitterrand à la
télévision
bien sûr que vous décrypter merci en
tout cas merci de nous avoir accompagnés
ça me fait plaisir d'avoir pu visiter ou
revisiter ses archives
aujourd'hui à vous de la télévision au
chantier sur l'élection de françois
mitterrand en 1981
merci à vous ludivine avant de refermer
cette inattendue notre traditionnel
pépite
cette semaine c'est une archive de 1983
un reportage de gérard pas bio vous
connaissez gérard pas mieux répondre aux
essais le maître du micro trottoir et
vous allez vite comprendre pourquoi les
pervers qu'en pensez vous je ne les
connais pas je connais les pères blancs
mais je connais
une femme légère je sais pas vous
comptez 1 m 70 si vous mettez 10 kg de
moins que connaissez-vous comme ce
catalogue alors ah ben je connais
j'attendais d'eux préférence des 3
suisses et puis la redoute
voilà on se retrouve mercredi prochain
toujours à 22 heures toujours sur le
canal 27 et toute la semaine bien sûr
sur les réseaux sociaux que ce soit ce
li na ou ceux de france info émission
préparée avec les documentalistes qui
avait beaucoup de travail cette semaine
avec les archives de l'élection de
françois mitterrand en 1981 à delaveau
laurence madiot l'inertie à elle et
merci à vous d'être présent toutes les
semaines
ici sur le canal 27
[Musique]